elvis little richard and tom jones on
the same stage it has never happened
until now a night to remember the
ultimate tribute show is happening this
thursday and here to tell us more is
derek david executive producer of the
event welcome to the show how are you
sir awesome it's great to have you on so
how did this all come together well you
know
one day i said to myself who was the
biggest act of the 50s elvis yep who was
the biggest black guy in the 50s the
platters so chris crosston said you know
what it's time that elvis met the
platters it's time that the platters met
elvis and they could do some songs
together that no one would think they
would do and then i said you know what
why don't i add tom jones and little
richard to the show to really make it
like put the icing on the cake with the
ladies of motown it is i was watching
some of the other videos you guys have
online and the people that you have
performing right i mean they are spot on
you you tell me it's an impersonator i
think it's elvis we're watching this
where's it taking place at it's going to
be at the library on flamingo park
library okay that's going to be 1401
east flamingo okay that's maryland
parkway
once you cross it on flamingo it's the
huge gray building right there and we're
looking at some of the pictures of these
impersonators this is the first time
that they've been on the stage together
for you yeah wow they're so they're so i
mean their mannerisms and their tribute
artists what they are they're they're
tribute artists how long is the show
gonna last how long we saw the
performers out there we're going to be
at least 90 minutes at least we know
that now uh we've been timing the show
and trying to keep it in that framework
but you know how that's going to run
it's vegas right it's freaking so
they're going to come out you know who
opens you know ed
uh yeah i'm going to have uh
ron garrett is going to be the emcee
he's going to open the show and then
we're going to have the crew who's my
band okay
with uh
it's a 11 piece band wow yeah yeah yeah
okay that's an eleven you got it lined
up yeah you're right right right right
so when elvis comes out how many songs
is elvis doing he's elvis he's doing hit
after hit after he have to hit after hit
after hit after hit then he goes off
stage then the ladies are not trying to
come on stage okay they do hit after hit
after hit please mr postman
go into the chapel
so they're going to do that and then
they'll come off when then when the
platters come on okay the platters will
do
three or four hits of their own okay
then when we come on with elvis we're
going to do songs by jimmy beaumont and
the skyliners like since i don't have
you okay we're going to have elvis st
park the plato's the thing park you know
and it's it's going to be one hell of a
hell of a night yeah you're on point
about elvis tom jones all these people
yeah yeah
good boy yeah i'm flying little richard
in from hawaii i love that gary moore's
coming in thank you so much man it's
been a great show really appreciate it a
night to remember is happening october
28th that's thursday right right seven
o'clock at the clark county library
theater call the number on your screen
visit
702-257-6085
jillian over to you thank you jason